winter is coming and it's time to honor
the dead
i did my list for the best 10 characters
still alive now it's time for my list of
the 10 best characters
currently deceased it should go without
saying but i'll say it anyway spoiler
warning if you are not caught up through
the end of season 4 on game of thrones
but if you are
welcome and starting at number 10 lock
you know i can't quite pin exactly what
it is about this character that i liked
but he was just
the right balance of this scuzzy
mercenary sense to him
without him being so skeevy that you
just didn't like having him around he
had
just the right amount of fun to him just
sort of enjoyment that he took out of
what he was doing i think a lot of it
just comes down to the fact that he was
not only did he chop off jamie
lannister's hand
but he messed with him before he did it
i think that was kind of what made him
uh
a fun character that i enjoyed in his
time number nine
egret you know there was a time not long
ago i would have bet she would never
would have come within a hundred miles
of a top ten list of any kind for game
of thrones with me but you know what
with the way that things eventually paid
out with her at the end yeah
she deserves some recognition what i
really like about her was that
they really committed to her turning on
jon snow when he went back to the crows
and went back to the night's watch the
fact that she shot him
in the back repeatedly with arrows and
then was still
prepared to kill him i mean yes moment
of hesitation at the end but that was
that was
just enough if they had actually like
both put their weapons down and hadn't
embraced you know what she would have
been way way off this list again but
they closed her out at just the right
moment where you get that little
that little sense of oh yeah she kind of
wishes this wasn't going on but
doesn't matter now you did number eight
rob stark
rob stark did grow on me over time when
the show first started i had a real
[ __ ] of a time distinguishing between
theon greyjoy rob stark john so they
just
it was kind of a wash for a while there
but to see
rob start to step up especially just at
the end of season one
when he became the king of the north
just to see him rise to the occasion and
take control
and to have that sort of royalty that
regal
kingliness to him he really did have
that as a general quality and that's
a hard thing to find but he had it and
he sold it
and you could believe that people would
want to follow him and of course
dying in one of the most infamous
moments in this entire story thus far
well yeah that's a hell of an exit
number seven
catelyn stark i know for a lot of people
catelyn kind of bugs them they find her
troublesome in that she just
causes a lot of problems because she's
driven so much by her devotion to
her family rather than looking at the
big picture and i get where those
complaints come from but
it's just so true to a devoted mother
and
wife that i think it really speaks to
the strength of her character
just the lengths that she's willing to
go to for what she genuinely feels
is the best for her family and what is
most likely to keep the members of her
family alive
and a bit like rob she has that certain
sense of inherent authority to her that
really helps sell the character a bit
more and again also like rob
heck of a way to leave the show number
six maester lewin
this is really just the strength of the
performance because the character
is frankly it's a generic it's a generic
elderly mentor character they're a
dime a dozen in any kind of fantasy
story well any kind of story at
all really older wise worldly mentor
character i mean
these guys are everywhere there's
nothing unique about the concept of this
character but
he's just so warm and yet so well
studied and so
knowledgeable and wonderfully
affectionate
in a very subtle way not overtly but you
really
do feel his affection his devotion for
the stark family
right from the beginning and he was a
character who i was very sorry to see go
i
i think that killing him at the point
that he did was the right thing to do it
didn't make sense to keep him around but
i was really sorry to see him go he was
one of those characters that when he
died i just got oh
no all right
number five the hound admittedly i'm
taking a slight leap of faith actually
putting him on this list because we did
not
see him die but i'm going on the track
record of this show which
is that there's no realistic way for him
to get out of the situation he was in
and he was left to die it's possible
that there's some way that he's gonna
turn out to be alive but that would be a
pretty big stretch and
this show doesn't really deal in those
kinds of big stretches and leaps to keep
characters alive so
i operate on the assumption that he's
dead if you ever read the books if you
know otherwise
please don't tell me but in any case
what a terrific
damaged character i mean this show just
does damaged
really really well and the hound is an
excellent example
starting out as just sort of the generic
scarred badass although
even in that first season you got this
certain sense a very
personal pain behind him there was a
quality to the performance that was a
certain kind of melancholy almost that
the only reason he was doing the things
that he is because it's all he can do
and he's so
good at it but then he really came into
his own when he was paired with arya and
he's trying to figure out what to do
with her that would get him the best
advantage and just
it just doesn't work out but the way
that the two of them actually
started sort of bonding but yet it never
developed to the point that she was
gonna do more than just leave him to die
and of course you want to talk about
great finishes
him and brienne of tarth that fight
was incredible and what a way to go down
number four tywin lannister you want to
talk about ways to go down
probably the most embarrassing one that
we've seen on this show but
you know what he earned those crossbow
bolts boy did he ever
you know i've mentioned about some of
these characters just the sense of
authority you have to them
this guy not only had a sense of
authority he had a sense of
menace to him and not necessarily a
physical madness like he was gonna
personally bash your head in but
you just felt from his very first scene
his very first time talking to anybody
and
if you don't remember it was him laying
the verbal smackdown on his son
the son he liked at that and just how
commanding the guy is i mean
you do not question this is a man in
complete
and total control of his immediate
surroundings and the situation going on
he knows what's what and he knows how to
get
all the pieces moved exactly where he
wants them to be
and yet despite this very sort of arch
construction he still felt very human
and you did get bits of emotion and bits
of
humanity out of him as the thing went
along really a strength of
charles dance's performance number three
oberyn martell
we'll get to how he ended up in a minute
but man
pure charm the instant he
showed up he kind of has that inigo
montoya flavor to him from the princess
bride i'm not just saying that because
of the accent
he has that swagger that charm but that
obsessive need for revenge at the same
time
like that's that's a hell of a
combination and it works terrifically
here i mean the guy just
oozes charm and appeal and sex but
then you see him start to talk about his
desire for revenge against the
lannisters and against the mountain
you're like
oh okay this guy is not all about
pleasure he is about some very serious
stuff too
and then of course we can't talk about
oberyn without talking about that fight
and the way he died oh my god
i mean that that death just
hurt to watch it hurt because it was
cruel and i mean cruel in every sense
cruel to the character
cruel to the audience and just a
horrible
horrible way to die number two
kyle drogo boy you want to talk about a
character who has left such a
lasting impact on the show but you know
what he was not around for very long
but man you intimidation factor
he just was so huge and so powerful just
the way he'd sit and just sort of look
at somebody
get that look in his eye and just think
somebody's gonna die
and yet he had that tender side he had
that love and devotion that he showed
daenerys
i mean you really bought that she fell
in love with him which
is crazy because she was sold to him
basically as a sex slave but
she brings out that softness and that
side to him without him losing his edge
at the same time and that scene
especially when he's going around
thumping his chest and he's ranting and
raving about how his son's gonna be the
stallion that mounts the world i mean
that
just amazing stuff and it's just burned
in my memory so strong even though it
was so far back at this point i mean
that's the sign of a strong character
somebody who
leaves that kind of impression long
after they're gone
and speaking of that brings us to number
one
ned stark you know for anyone who didn't
read the books and didn't know going in
the unexpected death and the wake up
call
to end all wake-up calls when it came to
this show when ned
died suddenly you realize oh wow i
had no idea what i was in for as i've
mentioned over time i've had a
whole ton of this show spoiled for me
death of ned stark was included but i
had friends who watched it who was as
well for them ahead of time
and they were even warned don't get
attached
to anybody they still weren't prepared
for ned to get it like oh but
not ned yes ned
ned the upright ned the honorable ned
the guy who's gonna do what is
most right the most objectively right
thing
and he's gonna get his head chopped off
for his trouble i mean ned
in that first season really was a beacon
he was a pillar
and for the show just to take a
sledgehammer and
wreck that pillar and not just come
collapsing down as a result man
that shows you how strong this show is
as a whole but he was a pillar he was a
rock he was what you could always come
back to is like
this is the one good guy in this whole
damnable world
well he was for as long as he lasted and
he was wonderful and he was
warm and he was devoted to his family
then he held on to his honor
and you couldn't help but just feel for
the guy right up to the point where the
sword
detached his head from the rest of him
so that's my list
for the top 10 deceased characters from
game of thrones
who is your favorite dead character on
this show there's quite a few to choose
from
so whoever it is leave something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council
is adjourned
you